[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on youtube how's everyone
doing today it's another fine day here
in south florida
uh hey my name's cameron
uh leave me a comment let me know who
you are and what part of the world
you're tuning in from
uh for those of you who don't know me
um i've been a motion designer for over
20 years
primarily work in after effects and a
little bit of cinema 4d
for 13 of those years i was a remote
freelancer
i've had the opportunity to work with
amazing clients amazing studios amazing
agencies
it's just been a really awesome career
um as a motion designer
and i want that for you so that's why
i'm here so today we're talking about
how to break into the industry
i get asked all the time how
do i get into the industry how did you
get into the industry like and how can
that work for me um but before i get
into that
um i want to hear from you as always i
want to hear from you
besides where you're you're tuning in
from and who's here
i want to know are you currently working
in the industry
and are you working in an industry that
you want to be a part of or maybe you're
you're being employed as a motion
designer but you want to work in a
different industry in motion design
maybe you're just struggling to get
completely into the industry like you're
not getting paid to do it yet
i want to know like what's your story um
you're trying to break in as a newbie or
you're trying to maybe break into
another industry
maybe you're trying to move up the the
ladder wherever you're at
there's a lot of different industries in
motion design you probably know that
um
so there could be a lot of different
answers here
um
but yeah that's what i got for you so uh
before i get into that let's see we've
got uh
nitham
nitham from the uk hello jw from the uk
what's going on jw
roy from new orleans awesome to have you
here
roy uh kermit
unseasonally warm here hey kermit
might hit 70. i heard that in the
midwest it's in the 70s my family's
still in the midwest
um
and that's crazy
here in florida it's still like 85
degrees which is normal it's still i'm
still sweating outside i just took my
dog on a walk and i'm sweating
uh let's see here
ignacio
sorry if i pronounce your name wrong hi
from mexico
hello
good to have you here
guadalajara mexico we have
uh bastard hardcore what's up master
hardcore
thank you for being here glad to have
you here
uh paul says i'm a news video editor
learning after effects is it too late
for me i'm 58 no it's not too late for
you i get i hear that a lot too no it's
not too late for you
i've had students in my courses who are
in their 70s and 80s
true story 70s and 80s
doing motion design having success
jw freelance web designer part-time
motion
tutor awesome
looking to work full-time in the motion
industry
awesome okay
jacob from slovakia what's up jacob from
slovakia
happy to have you here
uh nitham
recently finished education at 25 and
trying to get into the industry awesome
awesome
you know i'm curious i should maybe been
a little bit more specific guys i'm
curious
what industries like you actually want
to get into is it like doing corporate
work
is it doing
infographics is it doing commercials
advertising is it doing title design
working on films
that's what i'm looking for i mean these
are great answers as well
but i'm curious
you know like i have friends who are in
the corporate world who want to exit the
corporate world and move into like more
like advertising
or film work and things like that
so i'm just curious where you're at and
there's nothing wrong i have friends who
have been in advertising and like no
longer want to be a part of advertising
and choose to go into the corporate
world you know and the corporate world
is a very broad term
um and there's a lot of different places
i have a lot of friends who are very
happy in the corporate world i've done a
lot of corporate work myself because i'm
saying this because a lot of times
sometimes the word corporate has a
stigma to it
but it doesn't have to be some of my
most fun and engaging work and highest
paying work has been in the corporate
world so
um yeah
roy from new orleans awesome what's up
roy
um
and mo hey moe
thinking about film titles and credits
that's a great
industry this one that gets a lot of
people really interested in motion
design
like oh i saw this awesome title
sequence on this movie and got me so
inspired and i want to try that and
it's fun you know it's a lot of it's
very creative
uh nithm wants to get into motion
graphics for film preferably gooey and
phooey
screen graphics similar to territory
studios for perception yeah i absolutely
love their work
i absolutely love it
great answer jw title design worried
there isn't such a big industry in the
uk just for titles well here's the deal
jw
titles can be they don't have to be the
movies that you just see in the theaters
right it can be
titles can be
on
main mainstream films they can be on
independent films i've done a lot of
work on independent films
documentaries
for film release also for television
release
or internet release
titles can also be again on the
corporate side of things
[Music]
there's lots of videos that you never
see that are for like internal
corporations
um that
use title sequences uh even award shows
right they use title sequences so
lots and lots of opportunities for title
work
lloyd is interested in broadcasting i
love that
lloyd what's going on
long time follower good to have you here
and we have francisco
from milan italy amazing
amazing now guys if you have any more um
comments please do leave those in the
chat
um if you want to tell me a little bit
more about the industry you're trying to
break into i want to hear about it while
you're doing that
i want to let you know i have a free
workshop over at motionscience.tv
[Music]
workshop
and actually
i've
got here
motion science dot tv slash workshop i'm
going to show you seven secrets to
cinematic motion design these are seven
tips tricks and concepts
behind pro level motion design
plus i'm gonna give you access to a very
special offer at the end that you will
not find anywhere else so please check
it out if you have not already done so
it is motion science dot tv
slash workshop
all right
so let's jump in to
basically
since we're going to talk about how to
break it into the industry i want to
cover four
four basic
subjects that you need to four basic
points you need to to cover to break
into the industry and this is how i did
it this is what i have taught in my
course the freelance effect
this is what i have seen
work for a lot a lot of
people that i've known through through
motion science and through my freelance
career
the first thing point number one is that
you want to have a demo reel okay
now
that is that is the most important
bullet point in my four bullet point
list because
if you don't have a demo reel
um it's gonna be really really
challenging for you to
to get any type of work doesn't matter
what type of work you want you have to
have a demo reel to showcase your skills
and
show what you're capable of doing as
well as what you want to do okay so a
demo reel i've had other videos on this
topic but a demo reel
is your opportunity to say this is what
i'm really good at
and this is what i want more work of
so
for example let's say that
you've got this amazing demo reel and
let's say it's comprised of 10 different
clips of work you've done
and and let's say
you decide to add clip number 11 and
clip number 11 let's say all 10 clips or
3d bass or particle systems or or design
based or whatever and clip number eleven
is
character animation let's just say that
now
number one
seeing that eleventh clip is gonna
it's gonna throw me off as an executive
producer or creative director
because it's gonna be like why is this
piece in here and oh hey that looks
really good
maybe i'll hire this guy for character
animation when in reality i was short on
clips so i threw in this character
animation clip but i didn't enjoy doing
it it's not what i like to do so a demo
reel is your opportunity and you don't
want to get hired to do more of that
right a demo reel is your opportunity to
take the work that you're
that really like fuels your soul
and put it out to the world to say
here's what i'm capable of doing
hire me
pay me money to create more work like
this and it's this endless cycle like i
said i have other videos on on demo
reels out there on youtube
where i talk about the cycle of creating
what you want to create what creatively
fulfills you
getting more of that work getting paid
for that work creating better and better
reels getting better and better work and
it's just this endless cycle so that's
that's the biggest thing is that you
want to have
a demo reel you also want that demo reel
to be
what i believe 60 seconds is an ideal
length of time it can be shorter than
that it can be slightly longer than that
but
anything that's getting up there to like
the two minutes
is a little bit long especially with the
tension spans getting shorter and
shorter
so let me pull up here
a couple of examples
um that i i just did a really quick
google search
right before this this call
and um
i just typed in motion
design reel
and i pulled up three demo reels right
off the top here um that i thought were
hey these are great reels now there's a
few reels i saw that weren't so great
and um
i'm just going to play through these and
because i didn't want to point out the
bad examples i want to show you some
good examples here so this first one is
from um allison swear i don't know these
people like i said this was posted one
day ago
but let's take a look at this reel
and i want to pause it really quickly i
would love to hear from you guys if you
can hear the audio for this reel as i'm
playing it
i did a software update just recently
on the software i used to broadcast and
sometimes there's some weird audio
issues that happen
so i'm hoping that you can actually hear
this audio please let me know in the
comments
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
uh
okay so
54 seconds long plus we have a little
trailer here at the end plus we had a
little bit of intro for the first five
seconds so really it's like
49 seconds long and this is the reason i
want to play this reel is a great
example of
based on what i'm seeing in this reel
allison
likes to do illustration type work for
motion design and that's what i would
hire her for okay
um there's a couple clips without going
into like a demo real critique here
there's a couple clips i would remove
this being one of them this felt very
out of place to me
and this piece right here this now there
is some illustration happening here
but other than those two clips
um even the intro
and the outro here
are very um illustr like
she's got a strong sense of drawing
right and doing illustration type work
so
great use of a demo reel to say this is
what i'm good at this is what you should
hire me for
next demo reel
52 seconds long here if i can get it to
play
good old vimeo
[Music]
uh another great reel now a couple
little critiques on this one based on
this open here i'm like i'm thinking
okay
marie here is really into 3d design and
then we get right into these first
several clips and
it's power you know it's powerful 3d
it's really well done 3d
now there are some clips here where we
start getting like some illustration
type
motion design happening with some
footage
uh illustration again and then we get
back into heavy 3d
3d 3d 3d and then back in illustration
and then heavy 3d again now based on
this reel i know that marie is really
good at 3d and she's also
he or she's really good at illustration
now my critique of this reel would be to
mix up the 3d in the illustration a
little bit more because the first
front end of this reel which is what a
creative director is going to look at
the most is heavy on 3d so i know that
marie's really
interested in 3d
but then it just gets a little just
discombobulated with going back and
forth so i would kind of maybe try to
mix it together a little bit better but
a great use of a reel saying this is
what i'm good at and this is what you
should hire me for
i got one more here and this is from
matthew
[Music]
[Music]
again super powerful reel
you know 50 seconds long
super ideal length i mean i start to get
bored after 40 seconds or so of watching
any reel
but what i can
what i can gather from this is that
matthew is
really good at 3d
and matthew also really likes to work
with bright bold colors
so if my project requires that
then
that's what i'm going to go to matthew
for
so
great examples of demo reels that um
you know that that's the key number one
you have to have a demo reel
now maybe i'll do another video later on
about you know key aspects of a demo
reel
or you can check out the prelaunch
effect i talk about that as well inside
that but
key aspect number one great demo reel
number two
number two is you want to find the right
person to contact okay so now you've got
this real
you want to contact the right person get
this real in front of the right person
to see your work and know that you have
some talent
so
typically how that would happen for me
and for other motion designers i know
is um
first off i'm looking for a job right
i'm like out there scouring for
freelance work there's a lot of
different sites where you can look for
jobs
motionographer has been one that's been
around for a long long time since
the late 2000s i believe
and lots of great postings on here for
you know higher level motion design work
for the most part
there is some junior work on here for
sure though too
so what i would do is i would find
you know
possible jobs on here
some of these are just going to be it's
that's what's so great about going to a
site like oceanographer is that you can
typically just click on the job you're
interested in you read about it and you
can literally apply for this job
they pay motionographer to be listed
here so they make it very easy
for you to apply to this job and you can
see here they want to know your email
your name
your resume if you have one i don't
honestly think that a resume is that
important
some companies do prefer it
some don't i would say the majority
don't
so
obviously you can see here i don't have
a resume cover letter this is where you
can put in the same message that we're
going to talk about here in just a
minute with email
and we'll talk about this in a little
bit um but um
you're gonna want to mention your
website here for sure just to see your
reel okay
so that's an easy way to apply through
oceanographer if there's a certain
studio that you're interested in it's
really easy like i pulled up elastic
okay elastic is
elastic.tv
they're an awesome title design company
they also do more work outside titles
but i've always loved their work
for me i would love to work with them so
i went to elastic.tv
and found a contact button and here it
goes it pulls up
contacts here so i know that they have
different offices west coast east coast
midwest and canada they're a you know
pretty big company um so typically if i
was looking for a job with these guys
for me um at the time of my freelancing
i was in the midwest in kansas city so i
would reach out to
someone in the midwest probably and i
would email matt right here now maybe
matt wouldn't be an ideal contact and i
want to go more west coast or east coast
right here it's super easy you just
click on their email load it up and send
them an email and we'll talk about that
here in a minute
if these aren't you know alas this is a
great example of multiple people to
contact if you don't have these options
uh an executive in an ep executive
producer is typically who you want to go
with
they're the ones who are going to talk
to you about rates
check availability and things like that
before you get to the creative director
so an executive producer is always a
safe bet to go with
same thing here with imaginary forces
i
i've always admired their work
imaginaryforces.com
went there and clicked on info
and it pulls up immediately
career opportunities right here okay
there's also emails that we could reach
out to but because they do have career
opportunities i'm going to apply here
name first and last
email
what position you're looking for
i guess this is based on what they're
looking for now
because it's not a freelance
motion designer i'm probably going to go
ahead and exit out of here
and let me find the x here
because i'm not looking for that person
right now for me then i'm going to go
over here and find
general manager executive producer
tiffany and i'm going to email tiffany
directly and say
here's who i am here's what i'm people
doing here's my reel again we'll talk
about the the email in just a minute
prologue another company i absolutely
love um they
are pretty basic on who to contact so
you can see here title
and vfx live action and brand activation
contact to prolog commercials
commercials at prologue
because
there is just two basic emails here i
could
um send
an email to one of these two i'm taking
a chance because
this is typically for clients looking to
hire prologue
so what i might do at this point
is do a little bit more searching and
maybe like
i don't know maybe linkedin
instagram i don't know there's different
ways you can search and and search like
google like executive producer prologue
see if something comes up uh job
opportunities prologue and just try to
find that right person to contact uh the
thing is if you if you reach out to the
wrong person in the in this industry
there's a good chance your email is not
going to get forwarded on to the right
person because that person is not going
to watch your reel
because they're not going to know what
to look for right so maybe if it's a
smaller company they're going to forward
your email on to the right person but
there's a good chance your email will
get lost and you don't want that to
happen so
executive producer is always the best
bet second best bet is going to be your
creative director
third point that i want to talk about is
um writing a short email now the email
can be copied and pasted into job
applications like we just saw on
oceanographer
um but you're gonna write an email
that says basically
who you are
what you're capable of doing and that
you are
um
a freelancer
the biggest thing here is that you don't
want to look desperate okay you don't
want to send an email like hey please
hire me uh to be your your motion
designer
i'm amazing i can do the work
do not sound desperate it's more about
sending
what i would call availability emails
saying again
here's who i am this is what i'm capable
of here's my reel
uh i'm available for freelance
and you can even get specific on days
like hey i'm available freelance
starting uh december 1st
the second thing is is you want to use a
strong subject line
um
you know like
it can really vary on what the subject
line is
you don't want to send anything that
sounds spammy uh keep it pretty simple
after effects animator
hyphen freelance or motion designer
available for freelance something simple
but strong let them know exactly why
you're emailing them
the third point about writing emails is
you want to keep them short
you want to have
no more than two small paragraphs
you don't want a long story for someone
to read they don't have time
you also want to let them know what you
who you are what you do and you want to
be up front
and honest
about your rates
and availability okay so let me
switch over here
i've got a couple examples here i want
to show you
and
if i can get this to pull up correctly
there we go
um
here's a first example it's pretty basic
and short
and i actually pulled these from
emails i actually wrote okay so this is
back when i was first starting out as
freelancer
hi
very basic
i saw your posting on
could be motionographer.com it could be
wherever you saw the posting that
someone's looking for a freelancer
i saw your posting on motionographer.com
for freelance ae artist
sounds like a fun gig my day rate at the
time was 600 and i work remote out of kc
my reel can be viewed here
simple hyperlink to your reel so they
can click it and load your reel
thanks cameron appear on and then i
include my phone number down here
obviously they have my email contact
based on the email i've just sent them
but you do want to include a phone
number so that someone can reach out to
you right away i found a lot of times
that producers want to get on the phone
and talk to you
as quickly as possible typically
when you are
freelancing
a producer is in a rush to get you hired
right away now this can apply again not
just freelancing it can apply to
a full-time gig as well full-time job so
you would just change that out so hey i
saw your posting on blah blah blah for a
full-time
uh after effects artist
there you go
second email a little bit more
involved but still very short and simple
hi
i saw your posting on motionographer for
freelance ae artist i've been working
with after effects photoshop and
illustrator for about blank years now so
that tells them right off the top
i'm really good at after effects
photoshop and illustrator i have this
many years of experience okay
i'm self-taught and that's something
that i found that worked for me because
people were inspired by that you know
put in whatever you want to put here
have been making my way up the ladder
again this sentence isn't totally
necessary looking back on this
but it seemed to work
everything on my reel this is super
important everything on my reel is 100
my animation now when i sent this email
um i was not
a
designer at this point okay this is back
in 2006 and seven i was not a designer i
didn't know i could design yet i knew i
could animate really well so i was
letting them know hey everything on this
reel is 100 my animation a couple of the
spots throughout my demo you'll notice a
logo for prologue
prologue films these spots were designed
by prologue but the animation was done
by me
again i'm being very upfront very honest
about my abilities
and letting them know
i didn't design this i did animate it
okay
that's really important a creative
director and executive producer want to
know what you're capable of doing and
just showing them right up front like
hey i'm being very transparent was a big
yes to them
my most recent work has been for the mtv
video music awards and the abc network's
newest identity
again that's just a sentence here at the
end just putting a little bit more
credit to what my ability is
i checked that you're real and it's
totally sweet and that's pretty funny to
me to read that
um but it lets them know that you know i
checked out i'm really interested in
their company as well right like i want
to work for you
because i love what you guys are doing i
feel like i'm a match for you guys i'm
very interested in speaking with you
about your freelance gigs again this
could be um full-time opportunities my
reel can be viewed here hyperlinked to
the reel thanks cameron piron phone
number once again
super simple
to the point
that is what is important with these
emails guys i mean you got to keep them
short to the point
executive producers creative directors
are very busy people
and they want to just read very quickly
about you
what's your point what are you asking
what's your rate
are you available if they're interested
boom if they respond to you via email
they're typically very short emails as
well hey i like what you i love your
reel
if i didn't mention my day rate hey what
is your day rate
um
you know hey can we talk further again
they're looking for for short answers
from you just to get the conversation
going because they're very busy people
okay and the fourth
point i want to bring up to you guys
about how to break into the industry
is
what we just saw in the email you need
to link to a page
that shows your real
and a very brief description of who you
are okay
that is so so important especially on
the freelance side well even on the
full-time side um
producers
owners of companies creative directors
they want to work with good people okay
and so they want to know a little bit
about who you are
so
again
i talk about this more in detail in the
in the freelance effect
but
it's always a good idea just to have a
little bit a little bit of a sentence or
two about
who like who is cameron right who am i
what am i like you can even include a
picture of who you are um it's very
powerful and and producers seem to love
that
let me show you a couple examples here
uh ryan griffin
con he's so i go to ryan griffin's page
really simple logo you don't have to
have this
has his name
concept graphic motion and sound design
and direction i immediately know what
does ryan do okay
for me it would be like
designer animator creative director
immediately lets them know this is what
i'm capable of doing
here's an email address again this kids
feel like well why do i have to put my
email address i just emailed them well
you never know who's going to come
across your site and see your work and
want to know how to contact you so this
is always important that you put your
email there
i would also recommend your phone number
some people don't like to put their
phone number up on the on the internet
i get it
you can always use like a google voice
number that forwards to your phone it's
always an easy way to go about
putting a phone number up there for
someone to reach out to you but i would
recommend a phone number as well and
then a little bit more about ryan i make
art lead projects teach provide visual
concepts ideas and design graphics i
make things that move shoot and edit
film and video and can animate in 2d or
3d i mean hello this is like so much
information in two sentences about what
ryan's abilities are
i provide sound effects music and
soundscapes for use in headphones
commercials and films
awesome i mean just amazing it's so
short and to the point about what ryan's
abilities are i can also
garner from this
short description that ryan is
um
well like put together very well put
together
um
just because he's so
is so concise with the use of words on
this page um
tells me ryan's probably very organized
put together
knows what they're talking about
now if i scroll down a little bit
further
we've got the
most important thing the demo reel right
this is ryan's demo reel
again i'm going to see examples here of
what ryan is capable of doing and
that's the most important that's all you
really need on your web page
if you want to put a second page
you could do things like an about page
you know one main page here and if you
want to
you know expand a little bit more on
what who you are
maybe include a picture you can do a
simple about page
uh i don't think that you have to have
all these examples of work
maybe once you get a little bit more
advanced you can start putting style
frames and other pieces of work up on
your website but for that just to start
out and to get a lot of work a lot of
freelance work or a permanent position
somewhere this is all you need right
here now let's look at shannon wilkerson
uh shannon's a part of motion science
for those of you who don't know who
shannon is he's an amazing
cinema 4d artist
and
this is shannon's homepage
and we see
multiple examples here
of what shannon is capable of doing
there's also
an about me tab right here and you can
see there's a description here from
shannon about who shannon is
shannon is a motion design senior motion
designer visual effects artist and video
editor based in denver that's awesome so
i know where shannon's located at what
part of the world um it's also really
awesome to have a picture here to
connect with who shannon is
plus
shannon talks a little bit more about
imagination creativity
what he's capable of my broad skill set
allows me to join teams remotely on
location or taking projects from concept
to completion
amazing amazing
about me page
simple contact shannon's got a form here
that you can fill out and it'll submit
it and send it to shannon chan also has
socials here if we want to go even
further but you don't need all this you
just need to projects and about me if
you want to go that far
next i've got ben raddatz
ben is one of the founders of a company
called mk12
who were very influential to a lot of
old school emotion designers like myself
and
ben has so much work to show for himself
he could go on and on and on here
with his work i mean there's so much to
see
but you're gonna see here
right at the top ben raddatz motion
designer and filmmaker so we immediately
know
who he is
um and we have the reel right here's the
ben rad it's real if you definitely
check it out his work's amazing we also
have a simple contact page here
which we can do a form and an about page
right here with again ben's got his
picture
uh he's got a more detailed description
about who he is
his awards all that great stuff
and then finally we've got g monk here
who i just i didn't need to really show
this example but uh bradley monkowitz
just right here at the top you can see
his work
and what he's capable of creating he's
an amazing
director
uh digital artist
as you can see from the description here
uh more info about g monk
and kind of like his philosophy
um as well
as a um
[Music]
simple way to contact through email
um or through socials
so that's what i got um
let me switch this back over here
not that one
there we go
make sure i've got it all covered here
um so yeah so guys those are my um four
key concepts to how to break into the
industry in a very simplified term uh in
simplified ways number one make a demo
reel
number two
find the right person to contact and
reach out to them
number three write that short email or
cover letter in your application
and number four link to a page that
shows your real
and a very brief description of who you
are
those are such important points to keep
in mind and if you do
use those four points
you will
have success
in breaking into the industry
okay i'm gonna go back to some comments
here
reading through a few of them this is
always such an awkward point in the
video when i'm just reading these and
people like what are you doing
uh thank you for the nice comment
francisco i really appreciate that
uh yeah and you guys could all hear it
which i heard i saw that yes yes yes
music fits the animated yes i liked the
first animation better
and guys if you have any quick questions
i'd be happy to answer them for you if
maybe you've had any struggles with
breaking in the industry
um or what your biggest takeaway
from these four points are
um
quality yeah kermit says quality over
quantity i have to keep in mind for
myself when building a reel i've always
struggled with portfolios i've had and
i'm putting too much in them
yeah kermit that's a great point you
know even if your reel needs to be 30
seconds
that's totally fine um like a quick
five-second intro a quick five-second
outro
and
20 to 25 seconds of work
you want to put your best work on your
reel always and keep it to your best
work
um
and just quick and to the point as i
said attention spans have gone down i
just read statistics about how
i think
i'm not going to quote because the
amount of time uh not fewest the amount
of seconds for attention spans is so low
it's crazy
uh put your best work on your reel you
don't need to put all this filler in
there put the work that you want more of
in your reel and you'll be golden
shannon is amazing teacher just started
your cinema 40 quick start course
awesome yeah saheed great to have you
uh jacob says do you have any examples
of your favorite reels uh you know off
top of my head no
there's so many good reels out there uh
i mean there's so many good reels out
there i see a lot of reels on instagram
for the the people that i follow
and it's easy to get stuck in that world
and being like oh this is all there is
you know maybe i follow a few hundred
people on like instagram and i see some
of their reels
but just doing a quick google search
like i said
i did vimeo motion designers when i
searched i think and it was definitely
vimeo based though because vimeo hosts
the majority of demo reels from what
i've seen and um
i mean i found just some great reels
just right off the top just doing a
really quick search so no i mean check
out you know the big studios like like i
said mk12 ben raddatz that demo reel his
reel is amazing
um
[Music]
you know perception pictures elastic
imaginary forces i mean these are all
studios for reals but if you search for
freelancers you'll find some awesome
reels
yeah jw very helpful can this also apply
to making inquiries about full-time
posts instead of freelance if there
isn't a job posting
absolutely you use that email i showed
you and send it to them just letting
them know that hey i'm really interested
in your company i love what you create
um here's who i am and here's a link to
my reel
if you can you know ever have an opening
i would love to talk to you more
about how i could be a part of your team
short sweet to the point if you're real
as a match for this company they will
you know look more seriously at you
uh roy i started to find inspiration for
projects where do you find inspiration
to create a unique reel
uh so i have some videos on here on
youtube roy about that
but uh my main places are
instagram behance
pinterest
those are my three main sites that i go
to for inspiration and i create mood
boards
or boards in general
pinterest is a great place for that
and just build up inspiration upon
inspiration i have so many different
boards on pinterest with so many
different ideas um it's great just to
pull type from this board and color from
this board and texture from this board
and atmosphere and and just create just
have fun and create
also limit yourself with what you're
creating
but for the the key takeaway here is to
create work for your reel that you want
to get hired to create more of
yeah and so he said behance and dribble
might help you get inspiration as well
as pinterest yeah for sure
okay everybody i'm gonna wrap this one
up thank you for being here today i was
a great great uh youtube live
absolutely love being here with everyone
and teaching you what i know so you can
have success in motion design i'm going
to be out for the next couple weeks
celebrating the holidays with family and
friends and
all that good stuff so i will be back
probably early yeah be early january
january 4th
i plan to be back here and doing some
more awesome lives for you guys
and teaching you everything i know so
everyone have an amazing holiday uh
wherever you're at in the world and uh i
look forward to seeing you guys all next
time
have a good one